Hallo, herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute gibt es ein Rezept,
was sich schon viele von mir gewünscht haben:
Trileçe.
Trileçe ist ein,
also ich kenne es aus der Türkei,
ein türkisches Dessert.
Aber das gibt es auch in vielen anderen Kulturen.
Also ich will da nichts Falsches behaupten.
Und Trileçe gibt es auch aus dem Spanischen.
Tres Leches, also drei Milch.
Und dieses Dessert wird auch typischerweise
aus drei Milchsorten gemacht,
nämlich Kuhmilch, Schafsmilch und Ziegenmilch.
Wir haben hier jetzt nur eine Kuhmilch.
Die meisten machen das auch nur noch so,
weil man es einfach nicht mehr bekommt.
Vor allem auf dem Land,
also bei meinem Papa früher im Dorf
da hat man wirklich noch drei Kuh-
drei Milchsorten benutzt.
Da gab es das auch noch.
Aber bei uns hier ist es eigentlich...
Ja.
Also wir finden sie nicht hier.
Von daher mache ich es jetzt mit einer Milchsorte
so, wie es jetzt momentan in der Türkei zubereitet wird.
Das Dessert ist ein Milchdessert, wie gesagt.
Und es ist auch wirklich superleicht.
Also, wenn man es isst,
schmeckt es nicht zu süß
trotz einer leckeren Karamellschicht.
Und die Basis des Desserts
ist ein schöner lockerer Kuchen.
Und dafür brauche ich auch nur wenige Zutaten.
Sechs Eier, die sind bereits zimmerwarm,
250 Gramm Zucker, eine Prise Salz
und etwas Vanilleextrakt,
150 Gramm Mineralwasser,
150 Gramm Sonnenblumenöl,
420 Gramm Mehl
und dreieinhalb Teelöffel Backpulver.
In Kolumbien, Mexiko und Venezuela
wird übrigens das Dessert fast so ähnlich gemacht
nur ohne diese Karamellschicht,
habe ich gesehen.
Und im Türkischen wird es eben
mit der Karamellschicht gemacht.
Und die macht es auch wirklich superbesonders!
Also die Eier
kommen jetzt in die Rührschüssel,
wie gesagt, zimmerwarm.
So lassen sie sich besser und voluminöser aufschlagen.
Dann etwas Salz und Zucker.
Ihr könnt hier auch gerne den Zucker reduzieren.
Meine Rezeptvariante ist auch schon zuckerreduziert.
Normalerweise ist es noch süßer.
Aber dann ist es uns einfach zu heftig.
Etwas Vanilleextrakt.
Und jetzt könnt ihr die Zutaten für etwa 5 bis 10 Minuten
richtig schön cremig und
also so weiß, dickcremig aufschlagen
wie so einen Biskuit.
Danke schön.
Alter, whoa!
Der zieht einem die Schuhe aus!
Ein bisschen.
Boah, der ist echt gut!
Ist gut, nicht?
Hm.
Lecker, lecker, lecker!
Nicht wegschmeißen!
Meine Ohren sind ganz anders gleich.
Ja.
Perfekt sieht die Masse jetzt aus.
Da kommen jetzt die beiden Flüssigkeiten dazu,
also Wasser
und Sonnenblumenöl.
Jetzt ganz kurz einrühren bei niedriger Stufe.
Und ich habe hier schon mal
Mehl und Backpulver vermischt.
Ich gebe die Zutaten jetzt in ein Sieb,
damit sie nicht klumpen.
Und jetzt bei niedriger Stufe ganz kurz einrühren.
Viele backen Trileçe in einer Glasform,
weil ja später die Milch dazukommt
und der Kuchen getränkt wird.
Ich habe es aber auch hier schon
in meinem eckigen Backrahmen probiert.
Ist wirklich super!
Und der Vorteil ist,
ihr bekommt das Dessert später eben
auch wieder schön raus.
Ich kann den Rahmen später nämlich einfach entfernen.
Und aus der Glasform – ist wie mit Tiramisu –
bekommt man es einfach
– das erste Stück zumindest – nicht so schön raus.
Hier habe ich jetzt
auf große Einstellung eingestellt.
Ich habe jetzt auch eine Backfolie drunter.
Und hier kommt jetzt der lockere, luftige Teig hinein.
Und dann kann der Kuchen jetzt schon in den Backofen.
Und ich kann in der Zwischenzeit
schon mal die Karamellsoße zubereiten.
Die muss nämlich abkühlen.
Und da kann ich die Zeit schön nutzen.
Dafür braucht ihr auch nur diese drei Zutaten,
nämlich 170 Gramm Zucker,
25 Gramm Butter und 250 Gramm Sahne.
Die Sahne ist jetzt auch nicht mehr kühlschrankkalt.
Den Zucker gebe ich jetzt einfach in einen kleinen Topf,
stelle den Herd auf mittelhohe Hitze
und lasse ihn einfach karamellisieren.
Jetzt hier auch am Anfang gar nicht rühren,
sondern wirklich nur den Zuckern vor sich hin köcheln lassen.
Natürlich aufpassen, dass er nicht verbrennt.
Daher auch nur mittelhohe Hitze.
Und dann kann ich jetzt gleich schon mal
die anderen Zutaten richten.
Denn das dauert jetzt ein paar Minuten.
Jetzt sieht man hier schon ganz gut,
wie sich der Zucker auflöst und karamellisiert.
Da wirklich gut aufpassen!
Aber noch nicht rühren.
Einfach noch ein bisschen vor sich hin karamellisieren lassen.
Jetzt rühre ich hier ganz vorsichtig durch.
Der Zucker löst sich jetzt gerade noch,
karamellisiert aber auch schon.
Also wirklich vorsichtig sein!
Und die Farbe, die darf dann schon
so ein bisschen braun werden,
also ein etwas dunkleres Braun,
aber nicht zu dunkel.
Ansonsten wird die Karamellsoße nämlich bitter.
Muss einfach wieder schön klar und durchsichtig werden.
Sturmi, ich nominiere dich, dieses Rezept nachzumachen!
Was du aber nicht benutzen darfst,
ist die Turbotaste auf deinem Kochfeld.
Denn sonst karamellisiert dein Zucker nicht,
er verbrennt direkt.
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Und jetzt komme ich so langsam an die richtige Farbe ran.
Also so sieht das Karamell momentan aus.
Es sieht schon ziemlich fertig aus.
Aber ein bisschen karamelliger
beziehungsweise durchsichtiger wird er gleich noch.
So sieht es super aus.
Guckt mal. So muss die Farbe sein.
Und seid da wirklich nicht ungeduldig
und macht es wirklich nur auf mittelhoher Stufe.
Ansonsten verbrennt es wirklich superschnell.
Entweder zieht ihr es jetzt vom Herd kurz runter
oder schaltet den Herd ganz kurz etwas hinunter.
Da kommt jetzt die Butter rein.
Da merkt man dann auch immer,
wie heiß Karamell wirklich ist.
Und jetzt die Sahne dazu.
Und da passiert es jetzt gleich,
dass das Karamell fest wird.
Ist aber nicht schlimm.
Denn wir lassen es gleich sowieso aufkochen.
Seht ihr?
Es sah gerade aus wie so ein Ungeheuer, nicht?
Whaa!
Aber das löst sich jetzt hier gleich wieder in der heißen Sahne auf.
Also jetzt den Herd einfach wieder hochstellen
auf mittelhohe Hitze und schön aufkochen lassen.
So ist die Konsistenz jetzt gerade,
also sehr flüssig, aber trotzdem
fließt es so an einem Faden herunter,
wenn ich es vom Löffel runtertropfen lasse.
Ich lasse es noch kurz eine halbe Minute kochen
und dann ist die Soße fertig.
Also die muss wirklich schön flüssig bleiben,
nicht zu fest, damit ich sie später
eben auch schön drübergießen kann.
Zum Ausprobieren könnt ihr sie aber trotzdem immer gerne
einfach so einen Löffel voll
in ein Schälchen geben
und auskühlen lassen.
Ich schalte jetzt auch den Herd aus.
Und wenn ich gleich merke,
dass die Karamellsoße hier doch noch zu flüssig bleibt,
kann ich sie ja noch mal eine Minute kochen lassen.
Ansonsten ist sie wirklich perfekt.
Und die muss jetzt einfach komplett auskühlen.
Solange die Karamellsoße jetzt abkühlt,
kann ich schon mal die Milch machen,
also die zum Tränken.
Dafür habe ich hier einen Liter Milch,
200 Gramm Sahne und 100 Gramm Zucker.
Und damit sich der Zucker jetzt hier auch schön auflöst,
gebe ich die Sahne in ein kleines Schälchen.
Das muss jetzt nicht gekocht werden,
einfach nur erwärmt werden,
sodass der Zucker sich auflösen kann.
Es reicht also wirklich, wenn es nur etwas lauwarm wird.
Und wenn es dann nicht mehr so kratzt
am Boden,
dann weiß ich, dass der Zucker aufgelöst ist.
Und dann gebe ich die Sahne-Zucker-Mischung
einfach zur Milch dazu,
lasse es abkühlen.
Und das muss dann auch wirklich schön kalt sein,
wenn der Kuchen dann heiß aus dem Ofen kommt.
Der Zucker hat sich jetzt schön aufgelöst.
Jetzt kann ich es einfach hier zur Milch dazugeben.
Und, wie gesagt,
diese Mischung einfach schön abkühlen lassen.
Und jetzt noch die dritte Komponente
beziehungsweise die vierte herstellen.
Den Kuchen haben wir ja schon,
die Karamellsoße habe ich, die Milch.
Und jetzt kommt noch die aufgeschlagene Sahne.
Und dafür brauche ich jetzt einfach nur
600 Gramm kalte Schlagsahne,
etwas Vanilleextrakt und San-apart.
San-apart habe ich hier immer
schön abgefüllt
und nehme den Teelöffel.
Und die Sahne kann ich jetzt einfach hier
mit Vanilleextrakt verrühren.
Da kann ich jetzt hier die Sahne schlagen
und San-apart dazugeben und steifschlagen.
Aber, bevor die Sahne komplett steif ist,
muss ich gleich noch ein bisschen was rausnehmen
für die Deko.
Guck mal!
Jetzt ist die Creme noch nicht ganz steif
und ich brauche jetzt ein bisschen was für die Deko.
Ich habe jetzt hier einfach so eine Gefriertüte.
Die könnt ihr über ein Glas stülpen
und so ungefähr 50 Gramm,
das sind so drei Esslöffel,
könnt ihr hier einfach reingeben.
Und die restliche Creme schön steifschlagen.
Und dann einfach in den Kühlschrank stellen.
Der Kuchen ist jetzt nämlich auch gleich fertig.
Perfekt!
Die ist jetzt auch schön steif.
Die Creme kann auch zur Seite.
Der Kuchen ist jetzt gebacken.
Ich habe ihn auch 10 Minuten abkühlen lassen.
Aber er ist noch schön warm.
Und jetzt nehme ich einfach einen Zahnstocher
und steche hier kleine Löcher rein.
So kann die Milch nämlich gleich
besser hineinsinken.
Und hier kommt jetzt
die Milchmischung drüber.
Wie gesagt, ist die jetzt wieder schön kalt.
Der Kuchen ist warm.
Einfach ganz vorsichtig tränken.
Das sieht jetzt hier wirklich
nach mega, mega viel Milch aus,
aber, wie gesagt, das ist so ein nasser,
saftiger Milchkuchen.
Und den Kuchen lasse ich jetzt einfach abkühlen.
Ich stelle ihn dann danach sogar noch in den Kühlschrank,
damit er schön kalt wird.
Und viele nehmen jetzt dafür zum Backen
deswegen eine Glasform, weil sie denken,
dass einfach die Milch eben auslaufen könnte.
Wie gesagt, könnt ihr auch gerne eine Glasform nehmen.
Wenn ihr eine kleinere Menge zubereiten wollt,
könnt ihr es auch gerne umrechnen,
oder wenn ihr eine Glasform habt.
In meiner App könnt ihr nämlich einfach eure Maße angeben
und dann rechnet die App ganz automatisch die Zutaten runter.
Also ich kann jetzt im Prinzip nur noch warten,
alles abkühlen lassen
und dann geht es gleich weiter.
Perfekt!
Da läuft nichts aus.
Wirklich perfekt!
Jetzt ist alles schön kalt.
Und ich kann mein Trileçe,
meinen schönen Blechkuchen, einfach fertigstellen.
So.
Das Ganze habe ich jetzt noch hier.
Hier habe ich meine Sahne.
Die streiche ich jetzt zuerst mal auf den Kuchen.
Eine schöne dünne Schicht.
Einfach verteilen.
Die Fläche ist schön glatt.
Jetzt kommt die kalte Karamellsoße drüber.
Mmh!
Leckerschmecker!
Und die jetzt meiner einer sauberen Palette verstreichen.
Und darauf achten,
dass sich die zwei Schichten jetzt auch nicht vermischen.
Die Karamellsoße soll schön draufliegen.
Jetzt kommt noch der letzte Schritt.
Nämlich die
zurückgelegte Creme.
Hier schneide ich jetzt eine ganz kleine Spitze weg,
so eine Miniöffnung.
Ein bisschen größer.
Und damit ziehe ich jetzt hier einfach Streifen ein.
Aber ich mache das jetzt hier längs.
Und vom Abstand her so etwa zwei bis drei Zentimeter.
Und weil es jetzt noch nicht so ganz schön aussieht,
macht ihr jetzt mit einem Zahnstocher,
einem Schaschlikspieß
– ich habe hier jetzt einfach so einen Metallschaschlikspieß.
Und damit zieht ihr jetzt einmal von oben nach unten
und dann von unten nach oben so schöne Muster rein.
Okay.
Und dann wird es wirklich richtig schön!
Und das,
würde ich schon sagen, kann jeder.
Ich mache das eigentlich
auch nicht nur rein oberflächlich,
sondern gehe wirklich so einen halben Zentimeter tief rein.
So habt ihr wirklich dann eine richtig schöne Struktur.
Und fertig!
Und es sieht aus, als hätte es
jemand Professionelles gemacht.
Schon cool, oder, Josh?
Auf jeden Fall! Das könnte man nachmachen.
Ja.
Bis gerade eben hast du noch gedacht:
"Was macht sie da?" Oder?
Vielleicht ein bisschen. Ja.
Es gab schon schönere Sachen.
Perfekt!
Und so decke ich jetzt mein Trileçe ab,
lasse es schön durchkühlen.
Am besten wirklich vier bis fünf Stunden
oder über Nacht.
Und dann können wir probieren.
Und ihr seht,
das ist wirklich jetzt eine riesengroße Menge.
Also, wenn ihr wirklich Besuch bekommt
an Ramadan zum Fastenbrechen,
dann könnt ihr dieses Dessert zubereiten.
Es hält sich auch zwei bis drei Tage im Kühlschrank.
Schön verpackt natürlich.
Und wenn ihr sagt, ihr wollt eine kleinere Menge,
rechnet es, wie gesagt, einfach im Blog unter
– herunter.
Ich stelle es jetzt kurz kalt.
Und wenn es kalt ist, können wir probieren.
Das Dessert ist jetzt richtig schön kalt.
Ich ziehe es jetzt hier einmal vom Blech runter.
So.
Hi, Schatz!
Hi!
Ich helfe dir.
Ja.
Guck mal. Zieh du hier.
Eins, – partnerschaftlich – zwei, drei.
Krass! Okay.
Das ist ja ein in der Türkei sehr, sehr bekanntes Rezept.
Hm.
Wobei – Achtung – der Name
Trileçe heißt ja drei Milch, oder?
Ja.
Üç süt.
Ja. Und das kommt aus dem Italienischen.
Es kann sein, dass die...
Spanisch.
Spanisch? Ehrlich?
Es kann sein, dass man es vielleicht in jedem Land
ein bisschen anders macht, oder?
Meinst du, die Italiener haben das auch?
Also ich kenne es jetzt aus Spanien,
Kolumbien, Venezuela.
Ehrlich?
Ja.
Ich weiß ja nicht.
Ich bin mir sicher, dass bestimmt 20 Italiener da sind,
die sagen: "Nein. Es kommt von uns."
Eigentlich ist es auch egal, wo es herkommt.
Es schmeckt einfach richtig toll.
In der Türkei ist das richtig bekannt.
Und jetzt probieren wir es einfach mal aus, oder?
Hm.
Die Türken sagen jetzt: "Nee. Das ist von uns."
Whoaa!
Das sieht ja cool aus!
Das ist halt schon eine megakrass große Menge.
Ja.
Wie gesagt, das ist ein paar Tage haltbar,
zwei, drei Tage, eben aufgrund der Sahne.
Und jetzt nicht bitte auf der Dauerbackfolie schneiden
mit einem scharfen Messer.
Aber ihr könnt auch wirklich ein stumpfes Messer nehmen
so wie jetzt ich das Marzipanmesser.
Denn es ist schön weich.
Das Marzipanmesser heißt eigentlich Marzipanmesse,
man kann damit auch Fondant schneiden.
Man schneidet damit auch Fondant.
Eigentlich scheide ich meistens Fondant damit
Ja.
und fast nie Marzipan.
Ich müsste es mal umbenennen.
Und was ist, wenn man kein so Messer hat?
Dann kann man auch den Rücken
eines normalen Messers nehmen.
Ja. Oder so eine Palette.
Ah, eine Palette kann man auch nehmen,
So eine.
Genau.
Mach es mal mit der Palette, komm,
dass sie es mal auch sehen,
dass es mit der Palette auch geht.
Sauberer sogar als mit dem Marzipanmesser.
Ehrlich?
Okay.
Dann macht es mit...
Probieren.
Dann macht es mit der Palette.
Okay.
Und das ist halt so ein...
Ideal zum,
Das sieht so schön aus!
zum Kaffee richtig cool.
Oder auch zum Tee.
O mein Gott!
Können wir so wie so ein Pärchen?
Nein.
So.
Wir sind doch schon so lang verheiratet.
Das nimmt uns keiner mehr ab.
Hör auf mit dem.
Schau. Guck.
Okay.
Und jetzt guck mal, wie schön das aussieht.
Nicht so!
Nein.
Mmh!
Ich habe gedacht, einfach nur von einem Teller essen.
Boah, ist das cool!
Boah!
Wisst ihr, was das Coole ist?
Du hast den Teig.
Da hast du Milch drin, gell?
Ja.
Der Kuchen heißt Milchkuchen,
Drei-Milch-Kuchen.
Hm.
Pass auf mit deinem Löffel hier.
Mmh!
Und er ist nicht schwer, nicht?
Mhm.
Also das Dessert schmeckt total leicht.
Obwohl schon einigermaßen.
Pass mit deinem Löffel hier auf!
Ich muss noch Fotos machen.
War ich wieder lustig.
Okay.
Okay. Aber...
Ich meine, ich habe auch schon ordentlich
Milch, Sahne, – Boah!
Zucker drin, – Karamell schön! – aber
Mmh!
es schmeckt nicht zu süß.
Ich habe auch immer gedacht,
durch die Karamellschicht
dass das ein süßer Kuchen ist.
Aber gar nicht.
Mmh!
Und im Sommer total erfrischend.
Ja.
Ist jetzt das Schwierige an dem Kuchen
wahrscheinlich nur das Karamell, oder?
Oder ist das auch einfach?
Das war auch einfach.
Mmh!
Alles einfach, wenn man das Rezept beachtet.
Al senin olsun.
Danke, Schatz.
Also macht es gut,
macht einen Espresso dazu.
Probiert es gerne mal aus.
Mmh!
Ich schreibe euch natürlich das Rezept
auf meinen Blog.
Wie gesagt, könnt ihr es auch runterrechnen
ganz einfach in der App.
Also wir essen jetzt davon locker
mit dem gesamten Team schon so zwei, drei Tage.
Hm.
Nicht?
Ja.
Also ihr könnt auch gerne weniger zubereiten.
Das ist auch ein cooler Crowdfeeder, glaube ich.
Ist ein mega Crowdfeeder
und vor allem zum Ramadan Bayram.
Ja.
Zum Bayram kann man es super zubereiten.
Zum Bayram ist das bei uns eigentlich so,
Ja.
da kommen immer
Gäste, Familie.
Das ist eine ganze Völkerwanderung.
Dann denkt man immer hier:
"Was ist jetzt passiert?"
Aber ist bei uns einfach so.
Auf jeden Fall.
Also probiert es aus,
postet eure Bilder
und verlinkt mich darauf.
Dann sehe ich es
und dann kommentieren wir es auch
und liken es auch.
Ja.
Bis zum nächsten Mal!
Tschüssi!
Tschau!
Voll lecker!
Ich bin eigentlich kein Karamellfan, aber
Ich bin absoluter Karamellfan!
der Kuchen ist der Oberhammer!
Ja.
Wirklich!
Also die anderen auch?
Ja.
Kann ich noch mal ein Stück haben?
Noch eins?
Okay.
Für die anderen auch
und dann holt er sich selber noch mal ein Stück.
Ta-ta-ta-taa.
Danke.
Schön!
Was meinst du als Unparteiischer?
Mmh!
Ich muss noch mal probieren.
Also ultraweich!
Das ist voll soft!
Hm.
Auch lecker mit der Karamellsoße
und Sahne.
Du kanntest das vorher auch nicht, oder?
Mh?
Du kanntest das vorher auch nicht?
Mhm.
Aber es geht einfach so runter
also
kann man echt löffeln.
Mega, nicht?
Ja.
Wenn es nach mir ging,
könnte man sogar noch mehr Sahne draufmachen.
Echt?
Ja.
500 Gramm?
Ich liebe Sahne!
Also so eine Milchschnitte machen.
Ich glaube, der bleibt auch lange weich, oder?
Hm.
So zwei, drei Tage.
Also so saftig, wie der ist.
Also der trocknet nicht aus.
Vor allem hält er nicht mehr so lang.
Echt lecker!
Du musst mal probieren, Josh.
Ja, mach ich.